loved it I don't I didn't really think
about where it came from probably in the
same way that you didn't really think
about where your food came from when you
were a kid too
I don't remember exactly when I decided
to stop eating sharks in soup or when I
asked my family to but I do know it's
because of the stories I read and the
photos I saw and the videos I watched
and now as a storyteller I'm trying to
change minds - this is a photo that I
took in Sri Lanka not too long ago this
is my aunt she over there in the middle
that's my uncle he's talking to my mom
and my aunt is showing me where she
keeps her expensive dried seafood goods
like fish water and manta ray gills I
had I had no idea that she had these
things she starts showing me other
things she had she had cow gall stone
which she takes when she feels headaches
that are a remnant of a stroke she had a
couple years ago and to my surprise she
also showed me a small nub of rhino horn
that a friend had given her many years
ago for a thyroid problem if you asked
the english-speaking Internet they would
probably tell you that she were stupid
ignorant barbaric a monster but I know
she's not those things Chinese demand is
causing a lot of animals to go extinct
but when we make generalizations about
China this vast diverse country it's not
helpful even for me I sometimes feel
alienated or that I'm being talked about
like I'm not there as a visual
storyteller I've been exploring
traditional Chinese medicine its users
and where the ingredients come from this
photo is from a market in Guangzhou
where you can see that the amount of
wildlife being sold in this case sea
horses is absolutely mind-boggling I'm
hoping that my photos can help spark an
informed nuanced and pathetic
compassionate conversation about what's
going on if we're going to solve
environmental crisis we need to talk to
people we need to invite them to the
table and we need to involve them in our
solutions
we're gonna need nuance and compassion
and empathy and that's why I'm so
excited about our panel today because
that's exactly what it's about so please
join me in welcoming our first speaker
Dominique Gonsalves she's an ecologist
working at Gorongosa National Park and
she's a National Geographic fellow
thank you oops not yet
as a missing beacon women it's a great
honor to be here and to represent my
colleagues in Gorongosa National Park
Cougars is known to some of you as a
wildlife restoration success story in
the last decade our large population
animal population increased from 10,000
to 100,000 but thank you
but Carosa is in only about restoring
wildlife it is also about restoring
people's life when we see our Park in
the greater landscape and we think about
the challenges we face today we also
think about what can we do to ensure
that people and Wildlife has a have a
healthy and safe future this is some of
the reasons why going goes is being
successful first management Gorongosa is
calm managed in a 35 year private public
private partnership between the
government of Mozambique and the Greg
Kot foundation this partnership gives us
a lot of independence and flexibility we
can try new things and we can adapt
quickly when we see that one idea don't
work second
conservation and science gurgles efface
has many other wild places in Africa and
around the world many threats but we
have been holding the line our range is
reduced post poaching by 72% and they
kept the worst of the illegal wildlife
trade at our door so protection is
critical but you can't protect what you
don't know you don't you have so it
constantly documenting and monitoring
our biodiversity you want to we want to
know our animals and plant species
we want to understand these
relationships and how and what benefits
they give us this is what we do at the
EO Wilson Bird vest laboratory in
Gorongosa a month ago we celebrating
recording our 6,000 species and is
already going more and more third
benefits simply put a national park is
the opportunity cost to local people the
people can leave farm all hands there
and sometimes Bella finds that I study
go to their farms and raid their corpse
so you have to pay the opportunity cost
back to people and give benefits we
provide decent jobs to 650 people but
not everyone can have a job so we work
with the government to deliver health
care to people agricultural assistance
to family and education support
especially for vulnerable girls we
believe that when we give enough
benefits people listen and if you listen
back you become partners fourth funding
of course providing all these benefits
is expensive national parks are often
underfunded so we part we look for
partnerships with organizations groups
that normally don't do conservation but
they focus on human development these
groups want a reliable partner we have
the staff we have the infrastructure we
know the place we have strong
relationships with the people with our
communities so it becomes a win-win for
everyone but we don't want to rely on
donors forever
we are starting now to think of
sustainable financing funding sources
we are growing shade ground coffee and
Mount Gorongosa it not only helps
funding the park programs but also gives
income to the local farmer
and helps protect the rainforest at the
mountain
lastly tink long-term you know we as I
said we a long-term 35 years this way
the people know that you're not dead
just one day and gone the next
they engage they trust you and you also
have to think about climate change this
was brought to home to us on the 9th of
March 14th when cyclone II dies smashed
into Mozambique taking more than a
thousand lives destroying most of my
home city of beta and local communities
around Gorongosa during the cyclone the
park observed 800,000 you know Olympic
sized swimming pools of water overnight
our entire staff became relief workers
since then with we have delivered Teja
390 tons of foods over to seven to nine
thousand people we're now starting to
give seeds to farmers to regrow they
lost crops we are now starting a
multi-year effort to rebuild the schools
the clinics the roads the homes so you
can't just think small anymore for us is
more than just protecting a conservation
area now we have to leave to think more
than our borders and see our place in
the greater landscape because after all
all we want is also a long-term
coexistence and balance and I believe
that educating girls will take us there
the reason
the reason I'm standing here today is
because of Gorongosa efforts to change
gender norms and elevate Mozambican
women if you teach girls or women if you
teach women engage women and empower
women we will our I mean our potential
will be unleashed we will lift up our
communities and we will protect this
world places we all depend on for a
healthy safe future thank you
Thank You Dominique thank you next up we
have the director for Latin America for
national Geographics pristine seas
project Alex muñoz
thank you how do you imagine a pristine
sea looks like just all of us take a
moment I mean let's get a picture of our
pristine seas in our heads
do you have it well this is the picture
of a pristine see that I have in my head
for me looks like a watch the inside of
a watch
you have big wheels you have mid-sized
you have smaller wheels and although
they are all different they all make
sense together and they enable this
watch to give us the exact time if you
add a wheel or review lose one this
watch will be broken it will never tell
us the exact time anymore let me show
you a picture of this watch in the wild
ocean
this is Mexico the Riviera hey Islands a
few years ago we went on a pristine seas
expedition to this islands and we found
this incredibly healthy ecosystem with
all the right parts you have the big
fish the sharks the mantas the smaller
fish the algae and let alone dive in
there what an in believable experience
was to die with those giant mantis that
thrive in that place and now let me tell
you about a lateral watch in another
place in the South just imagine a brand
of a luxury watch
[Laughter]
let me tell you about Cape Horn in the
south of Chile a few years ago we went
again on any unbelievable expedition of
pristine seas to the south and in Cape
Horn we were diving in this kelp forest
and with my friend and colleague plyo
Salinas we were going down this kelp
forest and suddenly we saw that the
floor was moving it was very strange and
then we got closer and closer and deeper
and we saw these thousands and thousands
of crabs and dozens of different species
eating each other in this phenomenal
ecosystem a pristine an intact ecosystem
this is how the oceans should be like
but is this the image that we usually
see in today's oceans fortunately not
this is bottom trawling one of the most
evil inventions of humankind this is how
they're fishing hake very near Cape Horn
in my country Chile this is a sorry
coral reef that must be a thousand years
old that was cut by one of these
strollers and in north of my country the
fishing vessels of the world fishing and
Chariton saw this dolphins feeling in
this place and they decided to throw
this their nets anyway all these
dolphins died and very near they're only
two months ago they found this dead
dolphin that was a victim of fishing
with dynamite and you know the story of
the vaquita in Mexico the most
threatened marine mammal in the world
some scientists anticipate that this
species will be extinct this year
because of the bad fishing practices and
ineffective conservation efforts so the
oceans are in big trouble
and we have one more chance to say them
Enric Sala national graphic explorers
Explorer created pristine seas ten years
ago and we have an amazing team from
different fields and countries that most
of them are here
in this audience and we have one goal in
mind
protecting the last wild places in the
world's oceans and the way we do that is
by creating large money reserves not
that not only protect the rich
biodiversity but also a they bring the
fish back
they bring jobs back they feed people
and they make this marine ecosystems
more resilient to climate change so it's
a pretty good solution if you think
about it sometimes I get the question
what's the right approach for doing that
is that top-down approach do you just
shake hands with the President and then
just order the creation of Army Reserve
or a bottom-up approach do you work with
our local community and then wait and
till the rest of the society understands
their proposal actually we think that
it's both at the same time we work with
different actors different groups they
usually are in opposite sides or the
street opposite sides of a debate and
just make them be aware of effect
scientific facts and make them listen to
each other so they can build a common
solution together this is Juan Fernandez
fishing community and Fernandez is an
archipelago in Chile and it's one of the
most environmentally advanced community
I've ever met in the 1930s they already
figure out the way to manage their
lobster fishery which is to rate one of
the most sustainable fisheries in the
world and we work with them with for
many years and they understood the facts
the science that we brought and they
proposed the creation of the two largest
marine reserves in Chile and we have
worked with many communities young
indigenous peoples in different parts of
Latin America to do the same also we
work with scientists from our team and
local scientists that usually know more
about the place than us and we work
together and they perform this great
explorations to build the scientific
support for this proposals and we use
technology like this amazing the marine
or the drop cameras that was that were
invented by National Geographic and that
enable us to know the seafloor and they
see the
the deep sea like never before and we
put together this amazing documentaries
and these are so important because
unfortunately information doesn't move
the world emotions move the world and
when people see our shows they just fall
in love with this place press events
communities everyone want to protect
this places once they see our shows
recently we have incorporated a new tool
satellite images we have one mayor here
that does this amazing analysis to
estimate the economic impacts of closing
an area and we work with visionary
leaders like former President of Chile
Michelle Bachelet
that was brave enough to create three
large memberships that are the largest
in Latin America so is this enough now
we're going even further this is
something we should be very proud of
Chile and Argentina two different
countries
working with National Geographic
together on a joint expedition to
Antarctica Peninsula just remember that
both countries almost went to war 40
years ago because of a territorial
dispute and now they're working together
for science and marine conservation and
they have jointly proposed the
conservation and protection of Antarctic
Peninsula that's really outstanding in
terms of their relationship that we're
building so what has been the result of
this in a period of eight years Chile
went from almost zero to twenty four
percent of its waters projected creating
four marine parks fully protected
covering nearly 1 million square
kilometers of ocean Mexico created up
the largest marine reserve in North
America 150,000 square kilometers
protected in their original Islands
Argentina just created two reserves
jumping from two to nine percent of its
water protected adding a one hundred
thousand square kilometers of ocean
protected Ecuador created the first
large marine sanctuary in the Darwin and
Wolf islands in the alabama's Islands
which is the Sharky's place on earth
Columbia expanded its Marine Park from
7,000 to 27,000 square kilometers that
is fully protected so that's what has
been done in Latin America in total 11
big marine reserves 7 of them in the
last few years and our impact has been
even global we have done 30 expeditions
we have helped create 21 marine reserves
covering over 5 million square
kilometers of ocean that today are
totally protected
of course we didn't do this alone
nobody can not National Geographic in
other country not an NGO not a group of
scientists we have to work all together
and be very smart and strategic about
this and don't get me wrong that doesn't
mean that we don't see our differences
and and tell everybody what we think
about the problems we have a
responsibility to tell the world what
their problems are we have to be
faithful to the truth but the house is
on fire and at the end of the day we
only have each other to put that fire
out we have to work together that's why
we have decided to throw a more
ambitious project National Geographic
together with the West foundation have
lunch the last wild places and they can
pay for future to protect 30% of the
planet and we need to keep working
together we need each one of you in this
room and everybody outside this room to
be involved your support and your
engagement really matters thank you
our final speaker is an ecologist
working for the American prairie reserve
in a National Geographic fellow
please welcome ray Wynn grant
[Applause]
thank you I grew up in big cities and it
wasn't until I was 20 years old a young
adult that I had my first experience in
nature I went on my first hike I pitched
my first tent and I saw my first wild
animal and without a doubt it changed my
life because ever since then I have
dedicated my life in my career to the
study of carnivore ecology mainly
African lions and now I'm no National
Geographic photographer so these are my
own pictures of lions i collared and
black bears in North America and when it
comes to bears some people view them as
vicious ferocious animals that have
something against us but through my work
I've come to view them as quiet
dignified ecosystem engineers that have
a lot in common with people we like to
eat the same foods fortunately or
unfortunately we like to live in the
same places we're concerned about
raising our offspring in safe nurturing
environments and we all like to sleep a
whole lot and when it comes to bears
like many carnivores all over the world
some of the biggest conservation
challenges surround their interactions
with people and that has informed a lot
of my work and focused it in many ways
so my ecology work on carnivores largely
surrounds those populations at the human
wildland interface or at the spaces
where people and wild animals overlap
and it's this expertise that helped to
develop my fellowship with the American
prairie reserve a PR is on a mission to
create the largest protected area in the
continental United States located in
eastern central Montana a PR is working
to re wild part of the American Great
Plains and at the same time to work with
cattle ranching communities to create
wildlife friendly ranching practices
something virtually unheard of in many
parts of the world a PR is also on a
mission to diversify local economies to
support people and give communities a
very bright future and most importantly
to me we're working together to solve
human wildlife conflict problems and
even prevent them before they start now
a fully restored ecosystem in the
American Great Plains requires the
conservation of grizzly bears and other
threatened species in the ecosystem
these bears in particular are my focus
area right now and as part of a
conservation success story in the United
States they have been growing in
population size and migrating out of
protected areas like Yellowstone and
Glacier National Park faster than many
of us thought was possible they are
quite literally walking over to their
historic habitat in the Prairie and as a
conservationist this makes me very
excited however there are a lot of
people who aren't as excited and the
American prairie reserve and me and my
colleagues along with state wildlife
agencies small and large NGOs local
stakeholders and entire communities are
coming together and working together to
answer a lot of questions that are
arising
and to create really effective action
plans to make sure that we are
protecting wildlife where there are
people and protecting people where there
are wildlife and so these three
protected areas that will that are or
will be strongholds for grizzly bears
and other wildlife are very very
important and one of the most important
things is that there's some type of
connectivity between the three dispersal
isn't effective unless I'm sorry a
conservation isn't effective unless
there's some type of sustained safe
dispersal I am particularly interested
in corridors that might be found between
these three areas those three
strongholds create essentially a
triangle and we believe that with safe
corridors for wildlife as well as
stepping-stones of high-quality wildlife
habitat we can maintain effective
dispersal of individual bears as well as
genetic material between these three
protected areas this will lead to
conservation success and ultimately the
persistence of populations of grizzly
bears and many threatened wildlife
species in Montana and so I did some
work to fuse technical science with
fieldwork with basic bear biology and I
collected a lot of information about the
landscape everything from tree and
forest cover to waterways and things
about the human landscape like the
distribution of roads and highways human
population density cities and towns
coupling those things that represent the
landscape with basic science about bears
and carnivores their pure biology and I
used this information in a statistical
framework that uses circuit theory from
electrical engineering to make
predictions about how the landscape
looks to an animal what are the most
resistant parts of the landscape to move
and what are the most accessible or
least resistant parts of the landscape
that an animal might move through and
the most important thing about
conservation statistics of course is
data visualization nobody wants to look
at a lot of numbers and so I used as
remapping software to make these results
into maps that we can look at and the
maps show the easiest spaces that Bears
might use to leave Yellowstone and
glacier and recolonize their historic
habitat on the American Prairie
that's what you see in this image the
outline of the state of Montana and
these beautiful white lines that if you
focus on the center of the image create
that triangle once again it's proof of
concept we knew it from our local
understanding of the landscape and now
we knew it through a very rigorous
statistical design it's there these
pathways are possible and using this
type of statistical framework and all
these different knowledge sources allow
us to even ask further questions what if
we overlaid some of those pathways with
human land-use variables let's try one
that's really important to bears like
agriculture and ranching if we put the
locations of Agriculture and Lansing
landscapes on to this image it might
look something like this and all of a
sudden that beautiful triangle of
potential pathways for bears to disperse
between protected areas is slightly
obscured and this isn't new information
Montana Fish Wildlife and Parks and many
of the stakeholders and collaborators we
work with have been addressing what to
do in these spaces but in particular
myself and my colleagues at APR are
interested in those red and green dots
that you see around the American prairie
reserve grizzly bears are on their way
to our space but they're not there yet
and it gives us a tremendous opportunity
to go into the communities that we think
will be most affected by wildlife and
prevent conflict before it starts we're
bringing our ideas with us and we're
sitting and we're listening to what
people have to say
the land that they have owned for
generations and so the next step of my
work is to iterate the statistical
modeling approach and involve the
community even more than before
to get to the real stuff attitudes
tolerance levels belief systems and
include that in an actual statistical
framework to make further predictions
and to do a better job at addressing
people's needs and wildlife needs on
this landscape and so no matter if I am
being hands-on with animals or if I am
analyzing their landscape from a
distance I am very concerned with making
sure that science is addressing the
needs of people because the community is
the future of wildlife conservation and
what I've learned through my fellowship
thus far with National Geographic and
the American prairie reserve is that
there is this beautiful balance between
technical rigorous science and heart and
soul and a compassionate listening ear
thank you
thank ya so my first question to you is
what is it like to hold a baby bear
I love getting this question Laura and
baby bears always steal the show
so I usually like to have the attention
and then pull out a bear cub and no
one's looking at me anymore
but a lot of folks don't know that bears
and dogs have a common ancestor and so
little baby bears are a whole lot like
little puppies and so when you pull them
out of their den for a scientific work
only of course they're really cold and
so they want to snuggle and you just
have to put them in your jacket and they
like to lick your neck a little bit and
it really it couldn't be cuter I could
talk about baby bears for a long time
but I'm going to avoid invite the rest
of our speakers back on stage thank you
thank you all of you for your very
insightful talks so all of the stories
you shared we're pretty positive was
about working with people the people are
happy the animals happy we're all happy
but I'm sure it's not actually that
simple right can you talk about some of
the challenges you've had in your work
would you like to start Dominique
challenges I think we can talk about it
a lot all afternoon if I say a challenge
for me as a young women working in the
communities in going goes the first
thing is I'll say my sighs apparently
counts a lot because people especially
in the community first question is how
old are you
but then when we passed out of course
there's a there's a lot of healing still
to be done for the people especially in
Africa say to the people who live near
protected areas there's a lot of work so
people start to understand more about
the value of having it insted not
looking at it as a cost so for me being
in the field for example talking to
communities is always about how I
present myself and how I respect the
traditions and I do and the most
fascinating things is seeing other girls
and women and general people in the
community just looking at me fascinated
because I'm wearing pants yes but then
after that is also they also look even
more surprised when they see that I know
the traditions and I follow it and it's
very genuine because if they also mind
traditions so well in our case the
degreed of the commercial fleet is
really immense and we have to deal with
that every day the fishing industry
today fishes in 95% of the other world's
oceans and every time that we want to
protect the place
they are with their Lobby and they get
to the governments and they make phone
calls so we so they try to stop us every
single time and if there if it was for
them and they would fish everything out
I mean they just don't care about
sustainable fishing so there's a big
pressure like political pressure and
power to stop us from achieving our goal
so imagine how it's gonna be in the next
years when we want to protect 30% we are
very aware of that and that's why we
will have to be more effective and
smarter than ever it will want to win
yeah and I could talk about challenges
of course all of us as conservation
scientists can but one main one is you
know we're in the business of
restoration and the landscape where I'm
working with the American prairie
reserve the wildlife were extirpated
from that landscape deliberately right
it wasn't an accident that we have local
extinctions and that we're trying to
rebuild a wildlife community and so
along with this goal of rewilding comes
a lot of misunderstanding and a lot of
kind of cultural differences so for many
people in the landscape cattle ranching
or agricultural production means
something very deep in an identity way
and I may see as a scientist lives in
the East Coast has a lot of Education
and can do the modeling and create some
proof I might see a lot of potential in
a landscape but what's most important is
understanding where people's hearts are
and that's a challenge for both of us on
both sides for us to all realize that we
have the same goals we want to see
people thrive and we want to see
wildlife thrive without any feelings of
disrespect or mal-intent
so I found that you know I find math and
science and statistics really
challenging but even more than that it's
just getting to the heart of things with
people and building trust speaking of
where people's hearts are Dominique you
talked about how you're almost
incentivizing people to
support the park by offering benefits
like health care and education and Alex
you talked about hard is to get people
to care so my question is is there a
difference between incentivizing people
to support something and to get it and
to getting them to care and does the
difference matter when if it maybe it
leads to the same result or maybe it
doesn't well say in and around going
goes that people do care you know this
is the place is not just something that
someone brought and put in there with
it's always been there this deep
connection between the people and the
environment the forest the wildlife has
always says it's part of our you know
our beliefs our totem but as I said
again is this needful healing so not
only incentives but benefits actually
its provide decent benefits that you
know helps not only for people - I
wouldn't say care because they do care
to support but really creates a vicious
cycle because if we talk about a benefit
as education it's not something that you
receive today and it's over in a month
or so is something that builds up and we
will only see the return of that in
maybe five ten years so that's where I
stand is not just incentives is really
real opportunities in life that I will
create a virtuous cycle for us all well
my experience it's very important that
people feel some ownership of their
memory reserves that we propose I really
don't think that there's there can be
like an external force or maybe a just a
top-down approach where people just
order things and then they're as follows
in our case and I think this is going to
be even stronger in the future
we have to make people participate very
actively participate
and you have to listen to them and you
have to incorporate many of their
visions so the final solution represents
a whole of course we cannot satisfy
everybody because some people may say
you know everything should be open to
fishing and that's not what we want we
have to explain very clearly the facts
and the signs and what are the impacts
of each option and then be persuasive so
everybody's on board of one single
solution and we believe that marine
reserves when they are fully protected
and they are well located they can
satisfy things in a way that everybody
wins
like fishermen for example they when
they opposed to these reserves sometimes
they or most of the time they realize
that they protect one place then they
will be able to fish more outside the
reserve and and so on so everybody has
to understand what their share and how
they can win and then they feel actively
involved and be actually proud of the
reserve that is finally created yeah
well I have a great story to tell and
I'm so excited to tell it and it's about
my first trip to Montana to the American
prairie reserve for the beginning of my
fellowship and there's a big dinner that
was created up on the reserve which is
really hard to access and it was for
ranchers so it was a big dinner just for
cattle ranchers on the American prairie
reserve and one of them stood up and
said it is against every value and
principle that I have to be here and to
be a fan of a PR but I am and the reason
was that this individual and their
family had tried out some of the
American prairie reserves wildlife
friendly ranching techniques and a PR
has created a whole program called wild
sky ranching and it incentivizes
ranchers to adopt some environmentally
friendly procedures and in turn get some
extra funding on their ranch and the
trade-off is that they're doing
something great for the environment in
particular for large mammals so for
black bears for
mountain lions for some of the larger
bodied mammals that are there already
and this person is making more money
than they were before and also
facilitating the restoration of the
prairie and they didn't want to like it
you know and so it's exactly what you
said we're an incentive for an
individual actually was able to change
their action and their dedication to a
cause and it's a wonderful model that a
PR has developed that I'm trying to just
shout from the rooftops and we're hoping
that I can serve as a model for other
organizations within the last wild
places initiative earlier Dominique you
talked about how when you go into those
communities they're surprised by the
fact that you know the culture because
it's your culture - and on the other
hand you've also talked about how you
you work with people that you might
completely disagree with or you might
not understand who might understand you
so what's it is it important to have
locals working in conservation and if
you're not a local how do you bridge
those differences then we need to
Ontario locals as I said I'm here and
I'm from there I know the tradition I
didn't just learn to be able to do the
work but I grew up following those
traditions which make it very genuine
but it is important also that artists
and they come they follow it because
people needs to feel respected people
wants to feel heard and when that
happens they open many many doors one of
the things that happen was as I also
work with human and wildlife Cui's
distance I like to build a mystic when I
first times I went there was just a lot
of you know a lot of trauma a lot of
just hunger but he starts to just listen
listen more and follow the traditions
more for example instead of just wearing
go there wearing my pants I'll put my
traditional coat and they start to see
that actually she
many you know she she knows what she's
doing she's part of us so it became the
last thing it became that is not anymore
your elephants our farms is our
elephants in our landscape so this is a
big change that it takes time so whether
if you from there or not take time and
invest in listening and learning and
really just paint a tribute to the local
people because they'll be don't they're
gonna be the ones gonna really doing the
thing in the ground yeah and as you can
imagine them the opposite of Dominique
in a lot of ways where I am quite
non-traditional in the landscape where I
work in terms of identity and so it's
something that I'm constantly learning
is how to be effective with my identity
in my presence in the space I know
everything about bears I know everything
about them
I don't know everything about Montana
and that's really important I can't
pretend that I do and so coming with
humility and with sincerity and
authenticity is important and one cool
thing is intersectionality just as an
individual you know I am Who I am but
there are things that I have in common
with some of the folks that I'll be
working with or some of the people that
I hope to you know come into cooperation
with whether it's you know we're both
interested in a certain type of outdoor
activity I'm a mother and there are lots
of mothers in Montana and so that has
been a really great entryway into just
getting people to build trust and to
just find some common ground in order to
start those hard conversations
I like spite of your experience has been
working with local communities and
especially indigenous people is
fundamental it's all about very sincere
connection with them you have to work
with them in a very authentic way this
is not about just bringing a manual and
try to apply a formula this has to be
tried
made and you have to build up trust and
that means being with them and the good
and the bad times I in front Fernandez
for example who are Fernando Silas in
Chile I work with them for ten years and
the the change in the relationship I had
with them had nothing to do with the
marine conservation they were hit by a
tsunami and they lost half of the town
and they a lot of people were died in
that tragic event and I decided to stop
my work my campaign and raised some
funds with the organization used to work
for Oceania and we launched a big effort
to hire all the local divers to get all
the marine debris from the water so we
couldn't start rebuilding that place
then they said ok now we can work
together finally after eight years we
created the war Fernandez Marine Reserve
and the this venturus reserves that add
six hundred thousand square kilometers
of ocean protected thank you
unfortunately that's all the time we
have
I want to thank you so much for
everything you've shared and can we
please give them one last round of
applause
Thank You Laurel Thank You Dominic ray
Alex do you all realize that every half
an hour we are taking you on a journey
across the planet from Gorongosa to
Montana well a moment ago after I
introduced the VR session I realized
that I forgot to mention two very
important people the folks right here at
National Geographic Jenna pirogue and
Kate Mullen who actually took all of
that rubbish footage I had shot and
actually made that program for you so
thank you to them if they're watching it
on livestream now with VR it might be
limited to these goggles here there are
these headsets but National Geographic
Channel that all of you I'm sure are
very familiar with reaches a hundred and
seventy three countries 172 countries
and is transmitted in 43 languages
worldwide the next group of speakers are
responsible for the content on this
channel and thrilled to introduce Chris
Albert executive vice president global
communications and talent relations for
National Geographic partners let's
welcome Chris and his panelists welcome
[Applause]
all right how's everybody doing this
afternoon I am super excited about this
panel you know to put it simply it is
about storytelling and how we at
partners specifically bring the natural
world to life for our audiences all over
the world with some of the best
filmmakers and storytellers in the world
like the ones sitting next to me I'm
thrilled to introduce introduce Vanessa
Berlitz Martha Holmes and Chris Riley
I'm not going to read their BIOS because
there's nothing worse than a moderator
reading BIOS but I'm going to ask you
guys each a question and if you can give
us a little bit of your background as
you answer my first question that would
be great and one of my favorite
questions to ask everyone who is here
this week is about their passion their
passion for what they do so I would love
to understand and have you explain to us
where your passion for storytelling
comes from you want to start Vanessa
thank you thank you very much for having
me here it's a great honor to be in
these fantastic buildings and meet your
my passion of the storytelling probably
started as a kid with my mother who I
think probably if she'd had her time
again would have been a film director
but she weaned me on to American cinema
really early so whilst my friends were
watching Thomas the Tank Engine I was
being shown things like Papillon
Midnight Cowboy Raging Bull taxi driver
The Godfather as I got a bit older than
Blade Runner and were you when you were
watching Raging Bull so she was getting
bootleg coffees I don't know how she had
friends in the industry but so I that's
how I got my passion is like these were
great character studies and amazing
storytellers and tell us a little bit
about what you're where you're working
now what you do now so I'm very lucky
I've started a company with my husband
and a production company in Bristol
which is the mecca of wildlife
filmmaking well it has been four for
many of us and we are currently
producing two series for National
Geographic very honored to do so America
and queens and
of feature-length documentaries on
wildlife for Disney prior to that I had
many long years working the BBC and
worked on series like planet Earth
Frozen Planet planet Earth - and many
other hours single hours of television
we're very excited about the shows
you're working on for us so we'll get to
those in a second but Martha I'd love to
hear about your passion for storytelling
I had a very different experience
through Vanessa so I was animals first
and foremost and the outside world so
I've bought up on the shores of Middle
East and Africa
so the sea was my playground and I loved
escaping the stories as we all do I'm
sure dramas and so forth so I never
really thought about the - marrying
together so I chased my ambition to work
outside with animals and I tried being
an academic I'm sure all of you are
academics and it just didn't work for me
because I wasn't clever enough and I
just didn't feel them I any artistic
side in me was coming out and I hated
the data crunching and I just wanted to
be outside more so then I looked into
television and they're nice oh I thought
I just I'll just have a nice time being
outside with animals thank you very much
I wasn't very imaginative and then I
guess your life bills I'm sure you
haven't had this experience you get
layers and layers of interest as you
mature and grow and find new things and
I just so I went into the business just
wanting to be outside filming and then
the storytelling almost eclipsed that so
now my my absolute love is being in the
cutting room crafting the stories when
people come back from the field with the
footage so I would say it's it's a
latter thing I grew up on films and
loved it but I never thought my love of
a wild life would marry that and luckily
they have so so yeah I'm really blessed
to be in the cutting room crafting
stories and trying to give the audience
the best story we can possibly give them
thank you tell us a little bit about
where you are today so I am a head of
Natural History at a company called
printful productions it's not an
entirely wildlife company we do all
sorts of we call it fact and you call it
reality shows I think and science Docs
and all that sort of stuff so we're a
broad range but a large chunk of it is
natural history and like Vanessa I had a
history 25 years in the BBC for my sins
but it's a very very very good learning
school and you can you you know you you
start the very bottom and you learn
everything and then you can decide what
if you want specialize what you
specialize in so I was very lucky to
have that of my hinterland Chris well I
was about two years old when Neil and
Buzz walked on the moon almost 50 years
ago coming up this summer and by the
time I was five people were routinely
living and working on the moon driving
electric cars deep into the mountains
there three people even went there twice
it seemed like a really kind of regular
thing an extension of you know human
exploration and by the time I was about
eight
there were robotic probes landing on
Mars and Venus and sending back pictures
I had them all over my bedroom wall and
I guess it's hard to think of a bigger
more exciting story that captures you as
as a child at that age and then Star
Wars came out in 1977 I was 10 and what
George Lucas had managed to do in terms
of visualizing exoplanets almost 20
years before they were actually
discovered blew me away I mean I still
get sort of shivers down my spine when I
remember sitting in a dark room like
this and those curtains had moved
slightly wider on this screen and then
on would come the kind of edge of this
exoplanet there and so it was really a
passion for planetary science that I was
sort of injected into there through that
storytelling I guess and then there was
a really seminal edition of National
Geographic magazine I never told anyone
this story actually and it's perhaps the
best place to perhaps tell people for
the first time the January 1985 edition
and it sits on the board just outside
those doors there it's got Coco the
gorilla on the front cover it had the
most fantastic article on the planetary
geologists that were exploring the solar
system the moons of Jupiter and a little
bit about what we knew about the moons
of Saturn at that time so all over this
article and that was a seminal year for
me because I was deciding what to go and
study at University and I went straight
into into applied geology and planetary
science after that article came out and
I kept it I read it dozens and dozens of
times over the next few years it was
really like
changing for me and I went into science
after that I'm thinking I was a brainy
enough to perhaps do that and what a
mistake that was because actually you've
got to be so gifted to make a career in
science and what I realized I'd mistaken
actually was a love of storytelling for
a love of science and I have a love of
both but what I really found I wanted to
do was tell other people's stories and
like like you Martha I got into the BBC
soon after that and I spent 10 years
there and it is a wonderful wonderful
apprenticeship there to learn how to
tell stories and I'm still doing it
today
and you want to give us your quick where
you are right now well yes I've sort of
got stuck in lunar orbit a little bit so
I've just finished a children's book on
on all of the Apollo missions which
comes out next month called where once
we stood and I've written a big live
show that's going to happen on the MAL
here in Washington on the 19th and the
20th of July outside the Air and Space
Museum and up and down the mound we're
just cutting the film at the moment as I
speak and if any of you can get a chance
to come and see that I really urge you
to it will be in every sense of the word
awesome and I don't always use that word
so we were talking earlier you know the
Natural History world or the natural
world is not the same as it was 50 years
ago ten years ago even last year and
obviously as this group well knows you
know climate change is playing a huge
role so I'm curious how specifically our
changing world and climate change has
affected your filmmaking and
storytelling when it comes to telling
stories about our natural world Martha
you want to start yeah I think I think
somebody's Invitational interest might
be somebody else's turn off I think so
it's horses for courses you know some
programs you want to address it fully
some programs you want to accept it but
not lane you blame some programs if you
want another audience just don't mention
it at all so I think it's very no in a
hostile planet which we made recently
from that Geo we it was stated very much
as a fact but we weren't pointing any
fingers that the cause of of climate
change was never addressed it was just
this is what the animals are facing now
so I just think it's horses for courses
I think it's who your audience is who
you're appealing to you've got to bring
people in you do want to turn them off
if they're interested engage it with it
and if they're not then do a different
kind of programming Chris well this is
something we really grappled with when
we were thrashing out you know what kind
of beasts one strange rock would be and
I think there's there's been a massive
disconnect somehow between the
storytellers and at least half the
audience those that still perhaps come
to these shows that they appreciate the
kind of riches of the natural world but
then they go and vote at the ballot box
for the opposite and our job is trying
to bridge that gap a chasm if you like
actually as it is these days how do you
do that
is it something is it a floor in in the
stories and how we constructing them
when we first started asking ourselves
these questions for one strange Rock
what we came up with together was an
attempt to try and connect the lives and
ecosystems of the animals that are
featured in the series
with the lives of those watching in a
way a little bit like Pete Miller was
talking about this morning a sense of
what home is and how these creatures
lives feed into our own lives absolutely
and utterly directly there's no
disconnect with that and that was why we
ended up with this approach of using
astronauts to connect us to it to try
and examine the world with this overview
perspective but an overview perspective
is a very difficult and an intangible
thing to try and communicate most of us
haven't flown above 60 miles 100
kilometers above the atmosphere and we
don't really know what that feels like
however many times we're told so our
approach was to kind of connect these
small personal often human stories our
natural history sequences were often led
by a human being with the next breath
that you take for example in gasp
connecting you to the diatoms our heroes
of that episode or the nitrogen cycle in
the the salmon bringing the Pacific
nitrogen to feed the forests around the
Pacific Rim which maintains the entire
nitrogen cycle that keeps
keeps us alive another of our crucial
life support systems that was our
approach now have we achieved anything
that others haven't with that I I don't
know that's for the audience to decide
there was certainly lots of people that
came and watched it and said they liked
certain people that hadn't come to this
kind of subject matter before will that
translate actually to the sorts of
wonderful projects that we've been
hearing about this week here I sincerely
hope so but we're still waiting to find
out I think Vanessa I think I mean I
agree with everything you've both said
my feeling is that we need to use our
best storytelling skills and our best
advocates for the natural world which is
our animal characters and I think what
we're trying to do on the America series
that we're working with for National
Geographic is to use those heroes those
animal heroes to convey the experience
that they're going through today so
instead of looking at how their
experiences would have been it's to say
this is the real world for animals today
and particularly in America the animals
that succeed here are incredible at
reacting to opportunity and that comes
from living in a uniquely dynamic
continent where change is in every day
process every day is a brave new world
so it's it's actually a great way to
build the changing environment into the
storytelling and see it through the eyes
of the animal characters and I feel that
that you know we just have to get
cleverer and better at bringing the
reality of our changing environment into
our storytelling so let's dive into some
of the shows specifically that you all
worked on for us and I think I'm gonna
start with hostile planet I think one of
the things people don't realize is when
we set out to do one of these shows how
long it takes hostile planet you shot
over 1,800 hours of footage 82 shoots
1,300 days of filming I think you're
tired just thinking about it I think
some of you maybe have seen this trailer
but let's take a quick look at what was
accomplished during those 1,300 days
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this madness madness
I love that trailer I think I have seen
it maybe a hundred times our creative
team did such a good job on that and I
think it touches on what I think sets
this series apart which is sort of the
tone of the series could you talk a
little bit about the tone of the series
and the creative choices you made sure
so net Jia hadn't done a big blue-chip
Natural History show for awhile and the
BBC had been doing them and doing them
very beautifully and it's all very
lovely and will only go and that Jerry
wanted to set themselves apart and say
we want to do this differently and the
brief was to make it different raw
hostile that's the term we came up with
visceral granular truth and rather than
not sugar-coated because that's a bit
unfair and judgmental but or pejorative
but anyway so that was that's what we
set out to do so I know in the series
you didn't shy away from difficult
moments I've watched it with numerous
audiences and there were moments where
where they would shriek at watching but
you didn't you you didn't hesitate to
keep the camera just locked on what was
happening and sort of what was the
decision behind that well there's a lot
of debate about it obviously I mean we
wanted to tell the truth not only about
climate change again I said earlier and
we didn't we didn't point any fingers
but this is the situation and the
critical thing for the animals is the
world is changing and it's changing very
fast animals do evolve but they can't
evolve quick enough to keep up with the
time of climate change so it's how are
they doing as a sort of it was a mark on
the same saying how are these animals
doing and things are tougher and for
them and so the animals some survive and
thrive and do incredibly well and others
have a tough time of it we had chosen
not to pull back from the reality of how
hard they're finding it and how hard
they find it in a river in a normal year
when things are lovely and wonderful and
they're used to it all but things aren't
lovely a wonderful Easter doll it is
changing very fast so we just wanted to
be honest
technologically wise in storytelling
wise we very much wanted to be even s it
kind of touched on it on the side of the
animals we wanted to be on the animals
shoulders it's very easy in natural
history and historically we used to do
it where an animal will be over there
and you'd have a long lens and you sit
back and you'd watch the behavior unfold
I think audiences expect more now and we
needed do we really want the audio to
engage and feel that they were with the
animals so where we could we'd have been
with the animal rather than just
watching it as if you're watching it
through binoculars or something and
that's partly in the camera techniques
we use and it's partly in the words we
use so we some you know a word not
saying elephants do this but it's almost
like it's it's so let me just think of
an example a lion might be thinking it's
a hot day and rather than say well the
temperature outside is whatever it is 40
degrees centigrade and the minds are
feeling hot you say it's hot
you know shade is really welcome that
could be in the lion's head it's very
subtle but you're saying the same thing
and you're trying to be experience it
through the animal so we were doing
obviously we're working very hard on the
script make you feel you're embedded
with the animals or the camera shot to
make you feel that you know
traditionally you have a POV but we
tried to really embed the POV point of
view shots with the with the watching
the animal shot so is a lot of a lot of
work went into that and then technology
wise so you know for example we used a
racing drone very effectively
particularly in two shows one being a
golden eagle flying over mountains and
you know how birds of prey stoop so we
had this racing drone literally fly
unbelievably fast and these these
arrests these razor-edged edges of
mountains of things you really felt
you're you were with the golden eagle
and again in the jungles program we had
this tiny little hummingbird being
battered by drops of rain that kind of
were true and off knocked off balance
and then we had the racing gonna tell us
very funny story but it's a racing drone
and flying through the forest as if it
was a hummingbird and at one point we
were trying to endlessly wipe the lens
of that racing drone and then you told
actually no hummingbird is flying
through this water it wouldn't be
perfect so then we let bits of water
stay on the lens and suddenly it's a bit
blurred and the canoe
and you do feel it's more visceral but
uh no no the guy who runs this does this
racing drone thing he was doing it
through but not you know he can't see
where his drain is growing through that
the drone is going through the plants so
he's doing it all from camera on his
headset so he's what he's literally
flying with his eyes and he has a little
control mechanism he's amazingly good at
it but this little control panel has a
little red light and one of the
hummingbirds a hummingbird in the forest
thought oh that's a nice bright light
that's be a flower gonna get some nectar
so this guy's blind to what's going on
he's flying through the thing he's
twiddling or to loom this thing land
here and we call that the drone then
goes whoa and it's drain went flying off
into trees ya know I do when doesn't
because it's free it's a controlled way
there must be so few people in the world
who actually had the skill to buy a
drone like that I mean you really have
to see these people in it and if you
want to break into a new technology you
really have to get into the scientific
world and find these people who are
developing these things often for their
scientific research nothing to do with
filmmaking and then you try and adapt it
for filmmaking so one more quick
question about hostile planet and then
we'll talk about something else is you
know there was a little streaming
service that dropped a natural history
program at the same time as we launched
hostile planet it was beautiful but it
was very traditional had David
Attenborough you guys went with yeah you
you went with Bear Grylls which I
thought was an interesting choice as far
as his narration and his voice and can
you talk a little bit about that
decision and how he how he came to that
idea yeah well Bear Grylls like him or
not like him is a survivalist par
excellence
and these animals are surviving and they
are resilient and they're everything
that bear stands for he stands for
everything that they do day in day out
and actually he was kind of outside the
natural history world and and a bit of a
surprise but I think really really
fitted the show in terms of what these
animals they were trying to achieve
getting bad tuna rate and that for
history show for my Survival show was a
really long journey and again
fascinating one so he kind of stood up
for the first sentence and he's this
warm up a little bit and he says we just
little more gently and it took a long
time but anyway we just said my initial
thing was bear
just pretend you're reading to your
children at night and you want them to
go to sleep but I'm trying to get in
from over here to over here and just
soften the toad deepen your voice just
relax be really warm and invite the
audience in invite your children into
the story so he kind of went there and
I'm still expecting him to get over here
from over there anyway we got there and
to do him credit he worked really hard
at it and by the last few commentary
records it was Kevin was that he pretty
much nailed it I mean we had to do
retakes and retakes and retake some
retakes but we weren't over here anymore
at all he did he works so hard to get it
as far over here as he could say he was
great good to work with so live is
obviously a live television is obviously
another storytelling approach that we
take and plimsoll is actually working on
a show that we're airing in two weeks
called Yellowstone live last August we
went live from Yellowstone for four
nights and we're doing again starting
June 23rd so we'll take a quick look at
a tape and I'm going to ask you a couple
questions about that
[Music]
[Music]
this is real this is live that's the
magic in Yellowstone
[Applause]
so it's 4/9 25live cameras a large
number of remote cameras how do you even
begin to prepare for such a massive
production then ask me I might well
really own this is kind of guarding the
the wildlife in terms of the message and
and making sure that we get that right
how do you do it well
it literally is baby steps you have I'm
basically going to walk you through this
you have a sheet of paper with five acts
on it and there are little bricks and in
this one brick over time we want to
start live and we want to cut to amazing
wildlife we want to see some scenery and
we and we keep thinking we have to see
think about the glory of here I
certainly want some live and we got I
mean and there's various elements that
you're piecing in and you return to and
you literally fill out that wall of
bricks with we need to come back to that
here and that's there and we'll round up
the wildlife here and and you've
literally fill it in like that and we
know the animal characters the Bears the
wolves
the Eagles and you need a taste of all
women you want a life and I want in a
studio and it's just it's painting by
numbers because that sounds too
simplistic but it's building a wall but
brick by brick when you know what
there's each of those bricks is but then
when there's a bear coming over the
ridge and act to and you didn't know a
plan for that you kind of throw that out
the window a little bit some extent to
don't you yeah you have to be very
nimble and the chaos the chaos that goes
on in a live trap it and if you've ever
been witness to a live truck but there's
this massive truck with a studio inside
and everybody's talking at once I mean
literally probably 30 people in there
all talking at once to their microphones
or to each other with something in this
company important makes a program out of
it but again that's not my roles so I'm
fine about that but I think it's
interesting you know because obviously
NFL football live but it's like a
football field you're talking
Yellowstone which is like thousands of
miles
this is all pre-production I was talking
about the real thing is that the
knowledge the technical knowledge of
bouncing hiring you I'll hire a
satellite for two hours here in three
hours and we have teams all over and
between this hour and that we've hired
satellite time as you do and you bounce
all their signal they've been filming
all day and you get all eMeter a lot and
back down to the truck and then suddenly
the editors the moment it all starts
coming in there quickly packaging and
this is what we filmed earlier and
they're making these little short things
so that's all happening and the build-up
for the live show and then those cameras
are also live in a live show so we've
had what we filmed earlier packages and
you have the live cameras going
satellite and down but I'm not telling
logically minded so don't challenge me
on this I just I just know it kind of
goes up and down and out I run PR that's
about my knowledge - it sounds right
let's shift for a minute to a more
science focused series which is our
series one strange rock which were
incredibly proud of eight astronauts six
continents forty five countries and
something I had never seen in a science
Natural History series a large portion
of it from the International Space
Station let's take a little look at one
strange rock and then Chris I'm going to
ask you a couple questions
[Music]
[Music]
I'm going to tell you about the most
incredible place you know what
you're walking on it
[Music]
our planet is literally bursting with
life life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's so much activity and our planet
is right in the middle of it I really
wish that everyone could see the world
the way that I've had a chance to see
yeah
[Music]
the strangest place in the whole
universe might just be right here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so as the trailer shows Darren Aronofsky
was involved in the show and for those
that may not know who he is he's the
director of Black Swan and mother I mean
those are some trippy ass movies well
what was the sensibility and what did he
bring to this series because he'd never
done a television series before like
this no you're right he hadn't I mean I
think what what was clever about Jane
root our CEO nutopia idea was in
approaching him to help us with the
storytelling was it plays back to what I
was saying earlier about this challenge
we had of weaving stories together in a
way that just made you sit up and look
and think why I've not seen anything
like this before
just in an attempt to reach out to an
audience that panting perhaps hadn't
engaged with it before so I think
bringing him on boards and that happened
before I was involved with was was
really smart because he and his writing
and co-producing partner Ari Handel he's
got a PhD in neuroscience and great
science background as well proved to be
really instrumental in helping all the
producer directors shape their stories
and and they've they've really wallowed
themselves in some of these big ideas
and these deep philosophical feelings
about the cycles of life and death that
keep and maintain the planets sort of
fragile biosphere and they were all
themes that we wanted to include but not
obviously a vertically kind of Bosch
viewers over the head with so we needed
some way of engaging on a very human
level these subjects and connecting
people to them that way and letting them
make their own connections and their own
minds up I suppose but by showing them
as I said before I think about how these
deep connections between these small
moments in you know in a few hours on on
earth trunks fur and translate into
their own lives
utterly directly so yeah he was a useful
partner and right from the start they
were involved the two of them
particularly Ari in the script meetings
with us and helping us weave our beat
sheets together and
rewriting them I think I wrote 36
versions of my script before we went out
shooting that was quite a lesson I mean
it was like being at film school for a
year a lot of people would pay a lot of
money for that well yeah yes the master
classes were great I learned a lot
making this series and it was one
wonderful two years you talked about
this earlier but maybe we just touched
on too quickly which is the out using
the astronauts as our storytellers which
was sort of a unique way in nicole stott
if you all were here yesterday she was
actually on our opening panel who was a
big part of the series talk about the
astronauts as storytellers yeah so I
think actually Vanessa you were involved
early on before we came before I joined
with the initial discussions with Darin
about how to frame the series I mean you
might want to say something a bit about
the astronauts initially yes it was I
was invited out by Jane to spend a week
with Darren and his team which was
amazing experience as you say lots of
film students would pay give their hind
teeth for that and at that stage they
done huge amounts of research on the
science and it was incredible body of
work to take that much you know they're
very complicated ideas and distill them
down but Jane has said to me I don't
know what you're going to bring to this
but you might have an idea or something
and just see what happens and I was
absolutely terrified you know partly in
order of Darren Aronofsky not quite sure
what I was doing in the room and I sort
of stayed up all night thinking there's
something wrong it needs a kind of
framing for this series it needs a point
of view and that's when I was looking at
actually through my love of David Bowie
who I've often returned to and Chris
Hadfield and spiders you know because he
sang in space I suddenly thought it has
to be through the astronauts point of
view for the overview effect and he
loved it I think is an idea that you
immediately got it I think as a sort of
format but it's it's one thing to have
that idea in quite another thing to
translate it into kind of eight really
compelling astronauts personal stories
that interweave for those of the
planetary science and that was a real
challenge and I made a film with Apollo
astronauts a few years ago in the shadow
of the Moon and was well aware that with
the right preparation and casting you
could you can find and tease out the
most one
for personal stories from these
characters so we spent some month
casting to find the eight perfect posts
that we ended up with and I think Eloise
a noble producer and I looked at a
hundred initially a hundred estimates we
screen tested and we distilled it slowly
over the course of several months down
to those eight of which Chris Hadfield
was was very very much at the top of our
list from from from very early on given
his communication skills and then we
worked very closely with them over those
coming months to absolutely deep deeply
weave their stories in with our stories
and they had to be believable as
characters you absolutely had to believe
that they weren't just sort of telling
you stuff and the great wonderful thing
about you know 60 years of human
spaceflight now is that you've got a
pool of 550 people who've flown into
space all with different backgrounds in
science technology and medicine and the
arts sometimes as well and and they all
brought something to the science show by
fine-tuning our selection to the
episodes that way they were a
fascinating group I'd say we we did a
press event where we had all eight
astronauts on a stage with 200
television journalists who half the
times could give a [ __ ] about anything
and they literally all stopped and paid
they were solely focused on these eight
astronauts and they see celebrities all
the time and these these eight
astronauts stopped them in their tracks
and it was fascinating so for season two
which I'm excited if you don't know we
are hard at work on pre-production for
season two our storytellers are actually
going to be explorers which were super
excited about and we're in the process
of talking to a lot of people now and
figuring that out which i think is going
to be really bring a whole different
perspective to the series so I want to
touch on something you mentioned which
is point of view which brings us to the
series that we just announced a month
ago I think called Queens and I think we
have a slide for that because we have no
footage we haven't even started shooting
yet but tell us a little bit about
Queens because I'm super super excited
about this show I'm so excited to be
doing this show and it came about in a
really interesting way
for a long time and my backgrounds a
combination of anthropology and biology
so I've been very lucky to spend time
with indigenous peoples around the world
I was often documenting what the males
were doing and particularly rites of
passage and all the kind of sexy staff
of guys having their heads shaved and
going through dramatic rituals with
bullet ants and things like that but it
was often what the women were up to that
would intrigue me and the sort of the
power play that would be going on and as
I then transitioned into more Natural
History farming work the same thing was
playing out so I spent time in Gandhi
with the Gumby chimps and again there's
lots of kind of shouting and screaming
with what the males are doing but as you
dug into the depth of the studies that
are going in going on there with people
like Bill Wallower obviously under Jane
Goodall's auspices you realize the kind
of complexity of the female alliances
and leadership and actually how think
they're actually calling the shots so
this was again happened with gelada
baboons and recently I've been working
for two years in in Africa filming
elephants and extraordinary behaviour
amongst the matriarchs not all of it
cuddly for example we saw a rival herd
coming into a waterhole we've been
documenting the the particular herd in
front of us and suddenly the atmosphere
changed and it was war and these females
came in and they were like it is
flapping and they rushed forward and
took a new calf away from our matriarch
and it you know just as dramatic as any
kind of males in mus that you might have
seen they were full-on battling to get
this calf back our matric went in and
got her calf back and it was incredibly
dramatic and then it's another turn
you'd see extraordinary tender behaviour
from our matriarch where she would you
know rescued a stuck baby that wasn't
even hers from certain death so I've
become more and more intrigued and
instead of looking at what the females
within animal societies doing in this
series with we're taking the kind of
animal societies matriarchal societies
or matrilineal societies and we're
looking at how females compete rise to
power hold on to power and then what
happens when they lose power why do you
think this series has never been made
before it's kind of mind-boggling
actually when you think about it maybe I
think it starts with Darwin yeah genius
that he is I think the you know the
centerpiece of Darwin's theory is
obviously sexual selection and it was
very much slanted towards the way males
compete for females and that again it's
quite easy to document and to see
because it's dramatic it's heads butting
and I think that has skewed science and
in turn a lot of our filmmaking so if to
really look at what the females are
doing you need to spend a lot of time
you need to recognize individuals and
follow how the relationships develop and
you know this this story actually
developed out of a relationship that I
have been developing with Janet and
viscera where we've been talking about
this subject matter and both of us
feeling there was something there and I
had a smaller idea which was Knight
Queens which was to look at the kind of
battles between lionesses and hyenas on
the savannas at night and I said to
Janet you know I think I think there's
something here and she went in classic
American style we need to supersize this
let's do the six part on Queens of the
animal kingdom so the the Queen's idea
isn't just gonna be what we see on
screen but it's gonna manifest itself
largely behind the scenes as well yeah I
mean you know - it's great today to be
sitting here with another matriarch I
hope you're not offended by that but
[Music]
is going I think but but actually there
aren't many female leaders in natural
history filmmaking
it's I looked around in the sort of when
I was developing and learning my skills
and there weren't many women amongst us
so I think it's important to try and get
more voices into our industry and it's
not just about female voices and we're
trying to get we're really trying to get
indigenous voices from the cultures in
the countries where we film because
these the voices we need to hear as
Steve boys were saying earlier they are
the guardians of biodiversity so the we
very much have a bigger mission for this
series so that we incorporate more types
of people into the the production team
and work with more types of scientists
and field assistants so that we increase
that diversity well I know the reaction
when we announced that series both
internally and within the community was
just incredible excitement so I know it
may be we'll have you back in like two
years once we have something to show and
we can share it with everyone so I just
want to end on one last question for you
all because we're out of time and I said
I'd try to be finished on time I didn't
promise answer for me in a tweet type
sentence if you guys could make any
natural history series you wanted what
would it be
and then Courtney Monroe our president
will pick the best one backstage and
fund it no I'm kidding but Chris okay
well I guess for me being a plenary
scientist it would be perhaps the first
documentary about the extremophiles in
the depths of the Martian basins so fund
that I'm going to give away my secret
I mean biologist so I still feel there's
an awful lot to be done done in the
oceans that we haven't you know I think
that a blue pan and blue planet - were
fantastic but I think for a certain
audience they were and I think there's a
lot more we could do in the oceans that
will
bring a lot more people to the marine
world and the importance of it yep
Vanessa I'd like to develop the first
game that takes on the environment and
evolutionary theory so for tonight
so take the storytelling into the space
where kids are obsessed that's that's on
my bucket that's a different Department
so now we can find two things right we
the work you guys do and the time you
spend and the patience you have to
deliver these amazing stories to our
audiences all over the world we're
incredibly lucky to have you all working
with us and I just want to thank you all
for I couldn't find any American
panelists so thank you all for flying
across the pond to join us today we
really really really appreciate it and
again we're so honored to be able to
showcase the incredible work you guys do
so thank you so much and thank all of
you we just walked off this guy
Vanessa Martha Chris well now you know
some of the faces behind the spectacular
programs going on across the world now
our next group of speakers will
highlight solutions to biodiversity loss
and the different ways rewilding can be
used in conservation work please welcome
founder and managing director of the
American prairie reserve and National
Geographic Explorer Sean Garrity chief
marketing officer for African parks
Andrea headlock and founder X